[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
it's friday
the dark white house
has risen
and dark brandon is on the move
destroying manga republicans
absolutely eviscerating them
yesterday the white house's twitter
account if you weren't paying attention
it is one of the best
the best
lean into democracy threads that i have
seen in a long time and it came from the
official white house
absolutely incinerating republicans who
took ppp loans and had them forgiven who
were now saying it's unfair it's unfair
that
average americans have part of their
student debt
relieved how unfair i mean geez i only
got two and a half million dollars
i only got 785 thousand dollars
relieved and they get 10 this is
ridiculous i should have had more of my
federal debt relieved
give me a [ __ ] break the white house
absolutely eviscerating them
incinerating them it's about goddamn
time we all get on the same [ __ ] page
here
it's about goddamn time
and i know it's kind of funny to call it
dark brandon and dark white house and
it's great to poke fun at it
but it's about damn time
now i i'm not really sure
if the january 6 select committees in
the organization
that was created
with
the democrats
and the just the anti-trumpism
anti-fascism arm of this country the
antifa arm of this
country put together an organization to
message against these [ __ ] fascists
these [ __ ] criminals these people who
want to overthrow our government it's
ours
[ __ ]
i don't know if that helped here to
organize this messaging around
the student loan
relief but the idea the idea
that this is bad for america
is really [ __ ] stupid it's really
[ __ ] dumb
there's not much of an argument for the
oh it sucks for america
and they only played into
joe biden's hands as he went to rally in
pennsylvania
and burns their house down even more
some very significant one-liners from
joe biden that will be played over and
over and over again on social media only
only increasing not only his popularity
but now giving him the coverage that the
media can't help but give him and it's
always been i mean the media the media
was like oh what happens if joe biden
doesn't deliver student debt relief it's
going to affect him in the midterms
democrats going to lose because joe
biden doesn't
deliver on student debt relief
as soon as he does it as soon as he ends
the press conference
he know he no longer turns off the
microphone and turns away and the
media's like hey this is unfair and this
is going to affect you in the midterms
democrats are going to lose because
they're giving away handouts to the
american people it's not a [ __ ]
handout you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] it's not a handout they're
not getting [ __ ] money
they're getting relief from the debt
that the government put them in
this is really [ __ ] stupid
a lot of people have the debt and don't
even have a college degree
and they're they're they're over playing
their hand here too
they're the manga republicans that are
that is the america first nazi party
as they like to call themselves
they're really overplaying their hand
here and that was a great example
yesterday when the white house
absolutely does the absolutely right
thing
and calls them out on the rug
now they're not going to answer for this
you think marjorie taylor green is going
to be asked on any trader tv news
network
about the debt that she had suspended
and relieved and forgiven from the
federal government hundreds of thousands
of dollars that she took and ppp loans
when she acted like
the pandemic was fake
oh it's it's not real then what do you
need ppp money for
and marjorie taylor green if you have to
take
loans from the federal government why
are they forgiven that seems unfair huh
i mean that's what you call it
you call people who get their loans for
giving lazy
lazy pieces of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you marjorie taylor green
as she may now be known here is swattery
taylor green
i used to call her hoof foot
but now that she's being swatted by dark
brandon
not not like swat team but i mean like
swatted like a fly
now son of a [ __ ]
what a great day to be in america today
marks
the historic moment that the 19th
amendment was ratified
women received the right to vote in this
country now the maga republicans want to
take that away
but we're on to them and they know we're
on to them they're [ __ ] scared even
blake masters and [ __ ] nazi down in
arizona this [ __ ]
who who doesn't even think
women in america
are have equal rights at all wants to
take away their entire bodily autonomy
wants to make sure that little girls are
are forced to have babies he's excited
when a 35 year old woman dies from
complications of pregnancy because she
can't get a [ __ ] medical procedure in
texas to save her life he's [ __ ]
excited about that but he scrubs his
website of his [ __ ] pro birther views
because he knows it's getting more and
more unpopular these people these people
understand they way over played their
hand with row and there's row rage and
no better day than today when the 19th
amendment was ratified
to lean into that road rage
lean into it [ __ ] them
it's time we the people take our [ __ ]
country back now for this
nonsense this america first nazism this
mug of fascism [ __ ] them [ __ ] them we do
not have to listen to them we do not
have to play their little [ __ ] game
we can just do it ourselves
you have strategic outrage you have road
rage point it aim it direct it lean into
it and engage in your democracy
that's all you can do and that is what
is happening folks that is what is
happening even turning points usa has to
delete a dumb [ __ ] tweet
because they think they can just say
anything
they can just say anything just declare
anything they can declare anything
declassified they can declare who the
president was in 2020 as long as it fits
their narrative
the white house tweets out about the ppp
loans turning points
usa tweets out something about shut down
the government shut down the country in
2020. well who is the [ __ ] president
everyone points that out they have to
delete the tweet
they're running scared we got them right
where we want them folks
and it's very clear we just have to band
together stick together keep the
messaging keep the [ __ ] pressure on
because this midterm is the most
important election of your lifetime
if you want to keep your way of life in
this country if you want to make sure we
can get rid of the reality tv show
dumpster fire that is the [ __ ]
moglodites republican gqp america first
nazi party now is the time to engage in
your democracy now not last week not
next week not next month now is the time
and you can do it and it's not just
about marking your ballot
i mean you have the power of the ballot
but you have much more power than you
can ever dream of when you engage in
your democracy
you can help push the narrative
one of the best lines one of the best
lines from joe biden's incineration of
the republican party last night
was do you want your social security to
be in the hands
of ted cruz and marjorie taylor green
what are you [ __ ] nuts
what are you [ __ ] crazy
that is a great line i've been saying
forever do you want do you want matt
gatz to have control over your gas
prices you want these people to have
control over your economy what are you
[ __ ] nuts these people couldn't work
them way out with their way out of a wet
paper sack that's why they had to have
all their ppp loans forgiven
cause they're dumb [ __ ]
so lean into your democracy folks
it's time oh we're taking it back
and it smells it smells like victory but
just because you get the whiff
doesn't mean the fight's over doesn't
mean this election's over
you have to go to your community you
have to do what beto o'rourke is doing
in in texas he's talking to his
community members he's having
conversation about what's important to
them for democracy
not just about policy and light item
issues
but our
community as a whole
as an actual
democracy
and what power we have so exercise your
right to engage in the ballot
text messages
postcard writing door knocking if you
got extra money these campaigns need
money for the postcards for the door
knocking
it's super important
we can do it i yell and scream two hours
a day every single weekday monday
through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
on youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcast from the midas touch facebook
page you can do the same every day
at your church your community hall your
children's school the pta meeting god
damn it the line in the grocery store
super super important that you engage
and now do the thing that we need to do
which is democracy
if we want justice
equality and equity for all
that's what we have to do speaking of
justice and there's going to be some
news dropping maybe it has dropped since
i've been on the air it's possible let
me check out
the the the wires here uh
it looks like uh just in um the doj
proposed redactions and reasons are
released
um this is not the affidavit itself hugo
um
lao has this posted now i'm gonna
retweet it
um it looks like this uh
this affidavit is coming quickly
and it's gonna tell us now they're gonna
regret this
i mean this is always this is the trump
way they act like there's some some
great thing that's gonna exonerate him
on this affidavit it's only going to
incriminate him even more there's no
doubt and the reason why is because
there's three statutes that they that
this half a day that they used off its
affidavit to get the [ __ ] search
warrant in the first place criminal
statutes this is not gonna be good it's
not gonna go well for them even being as
redacted as it is it's not gonna go
[ __ ] well for him
and he's gonna try to lie in gaslight
about it i guess he's over on true
social and maybe we'll take a look
at some of those batshit crazy posts
today in the [ __ ] list roundup
but he's absolutely losing his mind
because he knows this is not good
now i know what they're trying to do
what the trump team is trying to do
because they're in the dark about this
affidavit just as we are
so they're not sure the exact aim of the
fbi and the department of justice
investigation here he knows what crimes
he's committed but he doesn't know which
ones they know about does that make
sense so he knows he knows what crimes
he's committed he was intentionally
committing them he just doesn't know
which ones they're really they know
about yet
and he's hoping this affidavit will tell
him which ones they know which ones they
don't know is what he's hoping
i mean it's going to be horrible for him
it's only going to put him in a position
where they're on their back feet again
the manga republicans that is the
bogledites
the dumb [ __ ]
but you
you as the democracy you as the
government we the people have to hold
him accountable i mean yeah the
department of justice and the doj the
fbi the florida government and new
york's government yeah we want them
those justice to be served in those
areas
but listen
you can indict and convict this
[ __ ] on in november with the
midterms
you can show the world
that yes
he's guilty as [ __ ] and anyone close to
him they're just as [ __ ] complicit in
this crime
[ __ ] them
you can do that you have the right you
have the right to vote it's up to you to
serve justice for the american people
when you engage in your democracy
this november you have the absolute
absolute right to go and indict and
convict anyone who is tied to trump by
voting for their opponent
which you should vote for the
pro-democracy candidate
because that's what we that's what we're
trying to do here and that's what
democrats have finally figured out stop
[ __ ] worrying about every line item
in a [ __ ] bill
we're not gonna get any [ __ ] line
items if we don't win elections you got
to win elections to get line items and
bills
who gives a [ __ ] about a line item and a
bill who that doesn't exist yet
no one gives a [ __ ] it can't happen joe
biden even said last night he said look
go vote for these senators give me two
more just two more [ __ ] senators and
we'll codify roe v wade we'll ban
assault weapons
he knows he can get it done he's just
gotta have a few more senators to get
that [ __ ] filibuster crushed for
these agenda items
and if you don't think that he's gonna
do it when he has the opportunity you
haven't been paying attention
the president of the united states joe
biden is doing everything he can to
deliver on the promises that he made to
the american people
and he's even going step further
i mean this student loan debt relief
takes a step further than what he even
promised on the campaign and what he
thought was
possible so you the people give him the
opportunity to do the things that the
majority americans want done in the
first place
stop having this [ __ ] stupid-ass
debate about the bodily autonomy of
american people who write who's has the
right over it rather the state has the
right to tell you what you can and
cannot [ __ ] do with your body
he wants to codify roe v wade he wants
to protect all americans in churches
community centers malls
schools elementary schools colleges
at [ __ ] fourth of july parades from
these [ __ ] weapons of war
he wants to do that
and i know you want to i know the
country wants to all they have to do is
decide to put people in place
pro-democracy people by the way because
that's the [ __ ] bar here
is just pro-democracy
you don't think that something will be
done on some of these issues if we put
pro-democracy people in place most of
the time people who have the
pro-democracy mindset have the mindset
that yes the majority of the democracy
the people
want a certain thing so we need to work
in that direction that's the progress we
need to make
that's what pro-democracy means
i mean we're not always going to agree
on every single aspect
but moving in that direction is
important that's why they're
miscalculating on roe they miscalculated
on on on the pact act they miscalculated
on this student don't debt relief
they're totally miscalculating
what the american people want
and we have to make them pay for it
that's the that's the issue that we have
is that if we the people don't band
together and do what we're supposed to
do and engage in our democracy then they
won't pay the price if you want them to
pay the price engage
not just vote i mean that that's that's
a bare minimum you gotta go mark your
ballot
but you have to engage in your democracy
you have to support pro-democracy speech
because the media is not doing a damn
good enough job here
i mean jesus christ i listened to the
media yesterday to see what they were
saying about the student donor left
student debt re relief and they were way
off way the [ __ ] off the mark even the
media is mis
guided about this
somehow this is bad for democrats and
joe biden what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
there are there are millions of
americans
if this if this stands and they can get
their debt relief there are millions of
americans
that now have unburdened themselves
from student debt relief that never goes
away this debt you can even file for
bankruptcy and this federal debt will
not leave your books
you always owe it
and you always owe the interest
they don't give a [ __ ]
but joe biden does
joe biden said no my federal government
is not going to do that to the american
people matter of fact they're going to
give them what they actually not even as
much as they deserve but a little bit
which is ten thousand bucks
because really in the grand scheme of
things i'm sure if you ran the numbers
more people are paying a hell lot more
than ten thousand dollars in interest
over the life of these loans
through forbearance and everything else
that the american people have to do to
afford these [ __ ] for the
lifetime that they have to afford them
because they go get the [ __ ] degree
and can't get a job that pays enough
so let them miscalculate
do not
do not
take the shovel
out of their hands when they are digging
their political grave
you just point out that you're doing
that that's all you do
is you just make it loud and proud and
say hey look look at these dumb
[ __ ] over here
ostracizing hard-working americans
hard-working i mean that's right
hard-working americans are the ones
getting this relief
not lazy americans that's such [ __ ]
that is such [ __ ] that's such
nonsense
there are so many few people who have
college debt that are lazy get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
we have record low unemployment people
record low unemployment
and a lot of times those people with
college degrees are [ __ ] getting
underpaid if you want to know the truth
most americans are
because corporations are [ __ ] greedy
and they don't want to pay people for
what they're worth regardless if they
have a college degree or not
talked to someone i know
last night
speaking of republicans the forced
birthers
this person is going to benefit
from this debt relief
she's a hard-working person she's a
veteran
she's a veteran she's a nurse her
husband is active duty
veteran
and military
went back to the military his active
duty now
they just spent thousands and thousands
and tens of thousands to adopt a little
baby
because they can't have their own
children they have to adopt
this this little one that they spent
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars to adopt which the pro-birthers
would love the forced birthers would
love you to have is to adopt all the
babies
well most people can't because they
can't afford to adopt
all this money so they could have this
child so they could raise a family
hard-working
her and her children are home alone
while her husband is active duty
and marjorie taylor greene and the rest
of the manga maglidites are demonizing
her
for getting a little bit of relief just
a [ __ ] little bit of relief from her
student debt
i wonder if she'll ever vote for
republican
ever again for the rest of her life
since they like to demonize her for
being lazy
telling you this is not gonna play well
in the country this oh it's unfair and
you're lazy
it's not gonna play well
i mean
we now know who the [ __ ] are like i
was saying yesterday if you see people
you personally know posting this [ __ ] on
social media like facebook
well you know who the [ __ ] are now
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] why are you such
an [ __ ] why are you so [ __ ]
concerned about someone else you always
want to talk about their [ __ ] bodies
what they can and can't do their [ __ ]
religion how they [ __ ] feel about
[ __ ] their faith
you [ __ ] want to tell them what they
can and can't [ __ ] read you can tell
them who the [ __ ] they can and can't
[ __ ] be
you can tell them who they can and can't
[ __ ] love
and now you want to tell them now you
want to tell them that they're not
[ __ ] hard-working americans well [ __ ]
you
that's what americans should tell these
mogalidites these manga republicans
these america first nazis is [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you unpatriotic pieces of [ __ ]
you [ __ ] traitors you have abandoned
not only our way of life but the people
in this country
so [ __ ] you
you can go straight
to hell and take all your bigotry and
all your fascism right the [ __ ] with you
stick around don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after these messages
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the tony
michaels podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babel maga
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that i'm struggling with i
chose battle mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
you god damn right i'm fired up god damn
right i'm fired up for our democracy
i'm fired up
[Music]
to destroy these manga republicans
it's time
[Music]
time we show them what the [ __ ]
democracy can do because that's the
that's the real story here these
republicans these fascists
this america first nazi party is
absolutely terrified of democracy
they're terrified of it because it will
deliver equality and equity it's a long
hard slog democracy is not easy folks
it's not easy to have a consensus among
this many millions of people hundreds of
millions of people it's difficult to
have a consensus
but we can get there it's the hard work
of democracy that takes us
but we will deliver more and more equity
more and more quality over time but it's
up to you it's up to us it's our
it's our democracy it's our government
it's our country it's our way of life
so it's up to us
it's up to us we we cannot allow a
criminal like donald trump to any get
anywhere near our government ever again
that's going to be no more clear this
morning than when this affidavit is
released we're waiting on this affidavit
um
let's see if we've got news here um it
looks like we're still
waiting on it to be posted uh by the
courts as soon as it's posted i'll bring
it up here on the screen um you know we
normally do the [ __ ] list around up
and we'll be rounding up the tweety
tweets and trendy trends but stick
around
all two hours today because we're doing
bonehead of the week
you know on fridays we go through the
bone end of the week poll you vote you
decide on twitter and youtube who is the
bonehead of the week me and my co-host
gabe sanchez break down your vote every
single friday for bone end of the week
and we're going to do that today in the
second hour but we're going to do the
[ __ ] list roundup we're just waiting to
see if this affidavit is gonna be
released um and what more importantly
what the affidavit says um here it is it
looks like uh let's um
let's pull this up here uh hugo has it
hugo has it here um here is the
breaking news
um
breaking redacted doj af david used to
justify the search warrant for trump's
mar-a-lago resort is released
okay so we'll retweet that we'll give
him a thanks and thank you hugo for
keeping us up to speed um so let's look
at this thing oh here it is
let's see if we can uh let's see if we
can put it up on the screen here
here's the affidavit here
uh let's see
i'm not going to read through it
we'll look at so you can see it is
heavily redacted of course a lot of
people are making jokes yesterday that
it was going to be so redacted that the
only word that was going to be there is
ketchup um so it's not as redacted as
you would think
it's not as redacted as you well here we
go here's the rejection
the redacting items 26 27 20 29
um most of 30 all 3132 there's a picture
there obviously or a piece of media more
likely a picture on this half dave 33 34
35 36 37 38 most of 39 40 41 42 so it is
the ass end of this affidavit is heavily
redacted um holy [ __ ]
uh so here's the thing
again with this affidavit
the thing that is uh really going to be
detrimental here is it's going to give
more incrimination for trump there's no
way that this does the opposite
because this is the document that they
use to go get the [ __ ] warrant
that and the judge granted them the
warrant based on three criminal statutes
so this affidavit
unredacted or redacted but unredacted
definitely
gives you gives you
uh
the
the reasons why they said yes he is
committing these criminal statutes we
know
we know
now the other thing too is this
affidavit redacted
is likely to show that as well
because what they're gonna try to hide
is not only
not only um names of the fbi agents more
than likely but also methods and sources
so that's probably what the ascent of
this affidavit is
is the information that they actually
collected um and when you when you have
when you have that situation they're not
going to release the information to show
what the source and how they actually
got it um because i mean this could be
array of things
like um
so so here here you see um here is item
30
which is not uh completely redacted but
it's heavily redacted it says according
to cbs
uh miami article titled moving trucks
spotted at mar-a-lago so this is about
moving trucks coming into mar-a-lago uh
this is january 18 2021 at least two
moving trucks were observed on the
premises so they knew there was moving
trucks so these boxes came in the moving
trucks now again there's heavily
redacted stuff so there's the there's
the method of how they tracked down this
article
and the facts in this article and
obviously the court and the fbi
department of justice does not want the
public to know
how they the their method for retrieving
this information based on what this
article reported right how they tracked
down the facts of that um because it
says right before item 30 boxes
containing documents were transported
from the white house to mar-a-lago
so in other words they're talking about
the transportation documents of course
here's a picture and i'm sure this
picture is of the [ __ ]
mar-a-lago box trucks
being unloaded
and taken into mar-a-lago that's
probably what it is i mean i'm just
assuming here i don't know because it's
redacted so
and again it might be redacted for
several reasons one reason could be they
don't want uh mj says go to 48
what's 48 48 on the uh what do you mean
47 because 48 is completely redacted
uh
oh for number 47 from may 16 to may 18
to 2022 fbi agents conducted a
preliminary review of the 15 boxes
provided to nara okay so this is this is
recent
okay so this was the original 15 boxes
that they took from the pres the
premises of mar-a-lago um when they went
the first time to retrieve our
classified to our documents our united
states government documents
so they reviewed them over a three-day
period it looks like and the fbi
identified documents with
classifications marking in 14 of the 15
boxes so only one box did not include
documents with
classified markings this is super
important here when you say classified
markings again they keep saying that he
did a sweeping declassification of these
documents and that is
categorically not how it works
appreciate the united states does have
the ability to declassify a piece of
information but it has to be walked
through the process you can't carry
around declassified information in a top
secret or classified folder that's what
they were so [ __ ] upset about when
hillary clinton's emails if you remember
there was one email one email that had a
small c remember that remember that when
james comey testified before the house
said yes it had a classification of a
small or a marking of a small
classification it was wrong but it was
still marked that way
right which is improper procedure that's
the whole point here that's the whole
[ __ ] point but this is this is that
email that one email on [ __ ] steroids
um so the classified markings of the
documents are in 14 of 15 boxes a
preliminary triage of the documents with
classification markings revealed the
following
approximate numbers the affidavit
reports 184 unique documents bearing
classification markings so not one email
184 documents including 67 documents
marking confidential it's marked that
way if he declassified these they
wouldn't be marked that way are you
understanding are you getting it you got
it in your thick [ __ ] skull mug of
republicans 92 documents the affidavit
goes on
marked as secret uh-oh and 25 documents
marked as top secret hillary clinton did
not have any emails marked top secret
she didn't have not one not a one
but here there's 25 documents that this
[ __ ] stole from our government
that are top secret documents no telling
who he was trying to sell them to
further the affidavit goes on the fbi
agents observed markings reflecting the
following compartments designation
controls hcs fisa oh god he's taking the
[ __ ] fisa warrants on himself
that's what i'm assuming
i don't know maybe not based on my
training and experience i know that
documents classified at these level
levels typically contain ndi which is
national defense information
so in other words these classifications
these designations here the hcs the fisa
the uh or con uh nor no foreign i i'm
not a i'm not an expert on these these
classifications and s i but this agent
who is reporting this who is getting
this affidavit
is
is up to speed on classified classified
information
and he is he is he is stating to the
judge in this affidavit hey this stuff
probably contains national defense
information and this [ __ ] should not be
outside of a skiff
is probably what this continues to say
the affidavit affidavit continues on
here in 47 of the unredacted part
several of the documents also contained
what appeared to be
uh former potus's handwritten notes oh
[ __ ]
oh man these are the ones he didn't eat
this is the treason notes that he didn't
eat
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me is that
what's going on here i don't know holy
[ __ ] but you guys are getting breaking
news here on the tony michaels podcast
go share this podcast right now right
now we're breaking the news number
uh our great moderator mj pointed out
numbers 47 here
about the 15 boxes and what they contain
184 unique documents bearing
classification markings including 67
documents marked confidential 92
documents marked as secret and 25
documents marked as top
secret
it also contains several documents that
appears to be the cheeto dust mobster's
handwritten notes that he didn't eat
i wonder if he put like
did he put cheese on him
and ketchup
and put them on a bun and eat them or do
you think he just stuffed them in his
mouth these are the ones he didn't eat
by the way these are the handwritten
notes he didn't eat or flushed down the
toilet
apparently in these boxes
my guess is is that they're probably
highly incriminating handwritten notes
seeing that who they come from this
[ __ ]
criminal
uh anybody else
oh here's here's another here let's see
what what's oh oh here we go number 52.
let's read through it
that tests do with their counsel
mm-hmm
that's probably the most significant is
number 47 at this point again the media
is going to pick this apart um these
reporters are going to go through this
affidavit at least the unredacted
parts
uh of this affidavit the parts that you
can see
and uh again just just number 47 here
um let me make a screenshot of this
thing and we'll post it on the twitter
account here
let's tweet this thing
just just this just this alone
uh is incriminating
it's it's gonna be a bad day for donald
trump and his team here a horrible
horrible day
absolutely horrible number 45 runs
into
number 47.
i think that's good
i don't know we'll see
we'll see
boom there we go i tweeted that
screenshot of that out so now you guys
can go look at that
um
the af did number 47 if you want to
spread it around the social medias
let me go to my twitter account here and
retweet that for a minute
again um
not good for donald trump
not good at all
here
um
reporting from this affidavit and
showing that the affidavit where he had
dozens and dozens and dozens
of classified top secret documents even
now which is not a great
great day for him so i just i just
i just
retweeted that onto my account so you
can see it uh there here is the um
here's the tweet
so go go spread that around the the
interwebs
number 45 runs into number 47 on the
affidavit i think i spelled it right i
don't know i was typing fast so if i
didn't forgive me
i'm not the greatest speller in the
world i'm just not
just not [ __ ] them okay let's go let's
do this let's do this gabe sanchez
should be joining us soon um i i think
he's going to be coming on soon he's
probably reading this affidavit over so
he can give us a little bit of reporting
of what's going on but let's do this
let's go let's we're going to do the
shitless roundup quick today because we
still have bone in the week we gotta go
through your vote a bone end of the week
in the second hour so stick around we're
gonna have that but right now we're
gonna go to the [ __ ] list roundup we're
gonna round up all the tweety tweets and
trendy trends i got a lot of footage to
show you from yesterday
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the tony michaels
podcast we have reached the part of the
show where we surf the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends on the [ __ ] list
roundup
a lot of um
a lot uh yeah uh gabe is texting me he's
reading through the affidavit he says it
shows that it has human intel which
means that um
um
which means that that that is probably
the informant so now he's working he's
working on um reading through that so
hopefully we'll have him on the show
here here soon but let's let's go
through the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends here on the [ __ ] list roundup i
have some footage i want to show you uh
last night it was crazy
crazy last night
um with
dark brandon absolutely destroying
republicans um here's here's an image
that
christopher had if you look here um at
this rally they actually had a a
powerpoint up let me make this bigger
boom
uh of
that's hilarious he's power dark
brandon's power pointing now
says jill biden now has a powerpoint
slideshow up for rick scott's proposal
the sunset legislation every five years
which means the president says would
include medicare and social security so
that's what that means
sunsetting means they have to you have
to re-vote on authorization of these
things they want to destroy social
security and medicare and the easiest
way to do it is to convince americans
that they're not going to do it but give
them the ability that's what they're
doing
so here's the thing so so they they want
to destroy the safety net
they want to destroy the safety net just
like they want to destroy the liberty of
women to have their bodily autonomy they
want to destroy children reading books
they want to destroy
the safety net in this country so they
can convince you that you don't need one
and here's what here's what's happening
here's what they're here's what they're
gonna do
they're gonna try to get convinced to
you that we need to sunset this thing
so that way they can change it around
every five years oh we can reappropriate
it we can recondition it no they want to
get rid of it every every five years
meaning they have the chance to get rid
of it and once it's gone folks that
motherfucker's done
so what are you gonna do rachel
bittikoffer points out something here
she says every candidate
and really every person
if you got family who's voting if you
got friends who are voting if you got
fellow pta members who are voting
if you got colleagues that are voting
you should be telling them this
every person should be telling every
voter about the republican party secret
plan to raise their taxes and steal
their social security and medicare
that's what they want to do
that's what they want to do thank you dr
rachel bittikoffer our favorite
political strategist here follow rachel
she says steal her tweets steal her
language
you could steal this from her just copy
and paste this she does not give a [ __ ]
she is one person you can steal tweets
from
she's one of the the smart she is the
smartest political strategist as far as
i'm concerned
in this country
and she loves democracy so much so that
she wants you to steal her tweets so
steal it steal the language change it up
a bit if you want whatever you got to do
it's important and i'm not just saying
just to retweet it i'll go put it on
facebook say it out loud to your family
your friends the person in the line at
the grocery store
i'm trying to find the um oh here's what
is this here's a clip
here's a clip from dark brandon from the
uh the rally last night in pennsylvania
what is this well let's watch
[Music]
dark brandon rises
oh my god
oh i'm we
that that is the great work of gabe
sanchez
if you guys don't know it's a great work
of gabe sanchez there of getting dark
brandon
[Music]
to talk about that here we go here's um
here is uh joe biden talking about women
and how manga republicans do not do not
understand the power of women listen
the court
minister's opinion use the phrase that
women have a right to vote and change
this well guess what
maga republicans don't have a clue about
the power of women
let me tell you something
they are about to find out
dark brandon oh yeah
oh i think we need to make a dark brand
of video like we did with the uh ted
cruz marjory taylor green social
security thing with this one what do you
think you think this would be a good one
we just just keep making this a series
or something
make this a series or something
[Music]
okay let's see oh that well
that is um
i need to go to a thread here let's go
to that thread
from the rally last night that's really
what i want to show you and
i have some other footage i have some
footage of zuckerberg talking about uh
100 laptop and the story of hunter
buying laptop on facebook a lot of
people are framing it up incorrectly of
course they are
um
now there's
more there's more um
marjorie taylor green there let's see
let's go to the thread
of joe biden last night
at the rally in pennsylvania
oh man there's so much video of these
[ __ ]
aaron rupar if you don't know aaron
rupar just absolutely knocks this out of
the park he's got so many threads now he
stays up with this stuff that's from
that once
there we go okay let's find the thread
here the joe biden video from last night
dark bright biden absolutely destroying
the mogla magladite republicans here's
here's the actual clip um that that was
from
from the dark brandon uh here where he's
talking about so it gives more context
of ted cruz and marjorie taylor green
having their slimy little hands all over
your medicare and social security
but i'm not joking think about this
think about what they're doing
and all
it's all there in black and white he
wants to require congress to vote on the
future of social security every five
years so every five years congress can
vote to change cut reduce or entirely
eliminate social security
how does that make you feel
[Music]
do you want to put your social security
into the hands of ted cruz and marjorie
taylor green
i mean it
but it's not just social security
senator scott wants everything in the
federal budget voted on de novo every
five years that goes out of existence
that includes medicare
veterans benefits and everything else
then along comes ron senator ron johnson
of wisconsin
this is what they put this in writing
now this is their plan
he thinks five years is too long
i'm not joking you think i'm making this
up
he wants to put social security medicare
on the chopping block every single year
there you go they want to and it only
takes once
that's the thing here is it only takes
once to just to get rid of it
it only takes one vote one vote to say
[ __ ] you you don't have social security
anymore
and destroy the program
that's all it takes
you don't have to have any more than
that
excuse me this this was in maryland i'm
i'm sorry i'm getting this confused he
was in maryland here
um
you know i got the i got the state
confused i'm really sorry i'm really
sorry here
let's see what other clips do we have
from this um
let's see here here's another clip of
him getting worked up
from aaron
we also included a provision that would
have allowed anyone with diabetes
including those kids
and their families
that should get charged somewhere
between 600 and a thousand dollars a
month
how would you feel like being a parent
looking at your kid
and knowing you didn't have the
insurance and knowing if they did not
get that insulin they may die
there's thousands of people
oh he's pissed dark brandon's going at
it and these republicans ripped that out
of the bill but we're coming back
hear that we're coming back dark brandon
has spoken
the dark white house has spoken
um
here's another here's another uh clip
about assault weapons ban from dark
brandon we took on the nra
and we beat them
we just passed the first significant gun
safety legislation in 30 years in this
country
and i promise you we're not stopping
here
i'm determined to ban assault weapons in
this
[Applause]
country i did it once before and we will
do it again
we're going to do it for those families
in buffalo uvalde newtown el paso
parkland charleston las vegas orlando
i've been to almost every one of those
places to meet with those parents
absolutely incinerating the republican
party here last night
um he's he's using the road rage and the
strategic outrage
for the rest of the from the rest of the
country
and he's pointing it in the right
direction doing exactly what he should
be doing uh here here he um gets someone
in the crowd let's watch this
and the whole notion of the burn it all
down politics of mega republicans
continues to be a drum beat
but
but
so there's a there's a person in the
ground saying you stole the election you
stole the election
let's see how dark brandon responds
no no no no let them go
let them go
let
let them go
that's okay
folks
folks folks
ignorance knows no boundaries
but we never gave up
we never gave in
and we're delivering for the american
people now
and now
even our critics have been forced to
acknowledge real progress whoo
gabe sanchez what do you say about that
clip absolutely destroying dark brand
holds nothing back man oh man we watched
the uh a dark brandon clip from earlier
someone someone made them oh weird i
don't know who yeah i don't know i don't
know i don't know who wouldn't make that
i have no idea that's great it's great
what what a what a great time to be
alive have you looked at this affidavit
yet i have
been i've been peeking through i've been
reading a few pages here uh okay well we
read number 47 number 47 page 47 yeah
well the item number 47 on the affidavit
item number 47. i actually posted on the
podcast page on the podcast page is
where i posted now this is important
gabe this this um
here it is here's the screenshot of it
here um 15 boxes provided to nara
containing classified information the
most important part about this is 184
unique documents bearing classification
markings 184 just in the first 15 boxes
this is this is the information that
they use to retain to get that warrant
in this affidavit including in those
boxes 67 of the documents were more
confidential you remember um there was a
lady ah they were freaking out about her
emails what was her name i think she
actually sat for like 11 hours and was
questioned all right
one email that was marked confidential
and something like some about um
republicans defunded security and
benghazi and they were trying to blame
it on her what's her name hc
yeah something like hrc can't remember
her name i think those are her initials
right hillary hillary hillary clinton
yeah that's it that's it that's it
hillary rodham clinton remember she had
that one email that was marked
confidential had the small c oh they're
freaking out i mean they did not want
her to be president at all but here we
have 67 documents in the uh 15 boxes
that uh the former guy the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy pants himself
stole from our white house um
really they they
and by they i mean republicans
republicans need to really
uh
decide what they want here because since
the beginning of this
they were like this is a this is an
attack directly from joe biden
this is
uh something that you had josh hawley
and ted cruz saying that uh that merrick
garland and christopher wray who was
appointed by president trump should
resign or uh be impeached right it
wasn't it's an attack it's an attack
it's a political attack it was planted
oh these documents were secure okay well
you know why did you have confidential
documents that were then or classified
that were declassified according to cash
patel but you also said they were
planted
and during this whole time they were
like oh release the search warrant and
then you find out more and they're like
wow well maybe release the affidavit
maybe we shouldn't release the search
warrant is what they're saying
everyone's like okay fine [ __ ] bet
we'll release it so they release it and
then they release another one last week
right i think it was last week yeah
after they asked for the affidavit like
okay no no we'll give you the uh more
detail to what the crimes were that
we're investigating for trump
when it comes to the search warrant and
they're like oh [ __ ] this does not look
good guys and then you know they have
kind of
kind of distanced themselves a little
bit and some people being like release
the affidavit well here you go you get
the redacted affidavit and this is
actually
i gotta be honest with you i thought
this whole [ __ ] thing was just
gonna be black lines well there's a lot
of it that is black because they're
trying to hide methods of how they got
this information right but this is not
secret right that's what's important
about item number 47 on this app david
it's not secret that nara went and got
those 15 boxes yeah that's not a secret
david well the only revealing
information here is what was exactly
right exactly so
184 documents 67 of them marked
confidential
92 of them marked secret
25 documents ma top secret the most
important i'm well i i don't maybe not
the most important thing but i think
it's the thing that we don't know it
raises the most questions here at the
very bottom it says several documents
also contain what appear to be the
cheeto dust mobster's handwritten notes
so these are the ones that he didn't eat
and didn't yeah right sharpie and all
right this is the ones that you didn't
eat and didn't flush but here's the
thing
here's here's the deal it's the reason
why this paragraph this item the number
47 is so important is because it shows
that they went through these boxes in a
three-day period yeah the fbi agents
conducted a preliminary review of those
boxes
14 of the 15 had classification markings
this is what is important
cash patel and donald trump and these
[ __ ] morons keep saying he
declassified him if they did not change
their markings they are not considered
declassified yeah that is a bunch of
[ __ ] malarkey as dark brandon would
say this is all [ __ ] you have to go
through the process of remarking when
you declassify otherwise it has to be
traded treated the way it is marked and
this guy had marked top secret documents
sitting in the pool house in melania's
closet you stupid [ __ ]
so you need to get off your ass and
realize that you know you are supporting
a [ __ ] traitor here
i thought about something earlier this
morning too you know i've been and that
specifically around you know what texas
paul was saying which is like oh he had
heard that the documents were in boxes
next to the pool room and that you know
we had been talking about this since
beginning he's like why does he keep
whining about melania's closet like he
clearly doesn't hate he doesn't he
clearly doesn't care for any of his what
current
or past wives he does not give a [ __ ]
about her or her closet but it's what is
in the closet
so i started thinking about this
you've seen photos of donald trump's
office right we even made it you even
made a comment about how for the
apprentice they had to like relocate the
like
uh the office set so they could have him
in a more organized clean office
do you know that we talked about that
uh yeah i'm sorry i'm reading no no no
no no no no it's fine but basically
something from hugo here yeah yeah so
more news about this uh let me pull it
up while you're talking about that go
ahead so basically what i was saying was
uh thinking more about
how donald trump works in terms of like
how he organizes how he stores stuff if
you look at any of the photos from his
trump tower photos right inside the
office you know especially it's just
like a [ __ ] right it's stacked all over
the [ __ ] place right
now these are generally a mess right
especially yeah yeah
exactly but i mean he he's exceptionally
disorganized and cluttered but right
this is something that i would say makes
complete sense if you look at his past
like the history repeats itself if
you're given a [ __ ] ton of paper a [ __ ]
ton of documents and folders you're
gonna treat it the same [ __ ] way that
you treated it with your past stuff
right the only difference is he put it
in a box and he stored it away but it's
not like he was like oh yeah let me
stash it in this secure vault or this
room or whatever he had it all over the
[ __ ] place like a madman stashing
money in the backyard because he thought
someone's going to steal it
that is the mind of donald trump here's
hugo on that point he says new redacted
doj affidavit says fbi believe that the
mar-a-lago storage room trump's
residential suite and the pine hall
whatever that is in mar-a-lago i don't
know if you can track that down and the
quote 45 office which would be his
private office i'm guessing that's where
his safe was and other locations were
all places where national defense
information documents were scattered and
that's the most important thing here is
the fbi and the doj was concerned this
guy had national defense information and
anyone who does anything with ndi or
national defense on information
understands that the majority of that
information cannot be held outside of a
skiff this has to be secure information
it doesn't matter the classification
yeah this is dude this guy is [ __ ] yes
all right so the pine hall and the
chamber is what it is it's an
anti-chamber it's the owner suite of the
mar-a-lago estate consists of a pine
hole an antichamber a vestibule
louis the 15th hall the undertone of
blah blah the pineal antichamber and
sitting room walls have wooden panels
uh
and trim large oil paintings above the
wainscot
are painted on canvas applied to the
plaster walls the fireplace blah blah
blah it's just a [ __ ] basic room it's
a double sided doors double rock windows
separate from the panel from the closure
so it's like so it's like an open like
an open room it's just an oh it's just
an open room like when i look at this
photo it's just like uh
it's just like a
uh i don't know the word to describe but
basically it's like over the it's very
trump it's it is um
like european
stock deco style like gold and is it
tacky as [ __ ] it's tacky as [ __ ] i'm
looking at a black and white photo that
is showing that's that's probably from
the original like the original photos
possibly or at least mar-a-lago wasn't
originally wasn't a
a private estate right and he's turned
it into this public golf course in this
country club and there's been videos
going around twitter um and i haven't
really reposted them and stuff because i
don't know how significant they are but
these videos show like tunnels walking
under different roads and
stuff around
and stuff and and these people i mean
there's there
you can walk on to the property because
the golf course doesn't have like a big
fence with razor wire around it and [ __ ]
you can walk onto the property and see
the private residence like and you don't
i mean you just walk on
right i mean they had a chinese national
that was arrested because they got on
not not just on the property she was
inside the [ __ ]
so yeah the other well the other thing
is um
is there were talks of
rudy giuliani using a passageway i just
yeah yeah that was this morning he was
he was living um i'm not sure if he was
living in a a a different guest star
circumvent type thing i know he's using
a pathway that would allow him to walk
to and from
mar-a-lago one of those underground
tunnel type things and and a lot of a
lot of um
golf courses have those because they
have cart paths right right and and they
don't want the cart path a lot of times
to intersect with the walkway so they
either put the walkway under or over the
cart path so the car path will be in a
tunnel or vice versa now kind of like a
highway with an overpass right you just
don't want that traffic you don't want
someone getting hit on a golf course i
mean i think everyone understands that
but but um what's the link you sent me
here so i just sent you a photo it's
black and white but i saw someone say
show the photos so this is a from the
library of congress it is a 1967 pine
hall anti-chamber to the owner suite
looking west at mar-a-lago
um in palm beach so this is black and
white but it gives you an idea of where
the documents were stored this is the
room where they found documents like a
cigar room or
there's nothing there's a part of it
yeah there is no place in here where you
go oh yeah i would store documents
especially i would store [ __ ]
classified government documents this is
not a place
where you would say yeah that makes
sense right i mean for donald trump he's
probably like oh you know what i'll put
it underneath this table and i'll just
i'll just uh cover it up or i'll just
like i wouldn't be surprised if they
went through that room and they found
other [ __ ] piled on top of those boxes
and remember this is just the first 15
boxes right this does not include the 12
boxes they went to get for the search
warrant
again this this affidavit is just is
just they they use the information that
was in the first 15 boxes and the
information that nara had of where these
things were stored the inventory where
this [ __ ] was stored to get the [ __ ]
affidavit to go get the rest of the [ __ ]
so who knows where the rest of the
shit's at or was that i mean and that's
kind of where the uh you know maybe the
pool house because they were
you know the [ __ ] that he wanted to sell
maybe or the [ __ ] that he wanted to keep
he was continuing to harbor this stuff
uh throughout the mar-a-lago compound
because he wanted to make sure he had
this [ __ ] in his possession for whatever
reason my guess is to sell the [ __ ] but
you know what do i know how can i make
that assumption i guess yeah right come
on everyone knows that's what it was
everyone knows this [ __ ] is
doing something nefarious with this [ __ ]
we that that's that's we know
there's no other reason why he would
have the documents like he's not again
he's not scrapbooking [ __ ]
confidentially getting my [ __ ]
elmer's glue stick out here and i'm
putting it on like a poster board to be
like oh i remember those days when when
we had that you know redacted thing that
we did or that other redacted thing that
was done like that's not and these are
the things that wouldn't be redacted
right these would be the these are the
unredacted confidential classified top
secret documents that should not be in
the preview or or i kind of range of
anyone who does not have the
classification
or authority to do so and the fact that
they're stored in a room just like this
or they're stored in some basement or
they're easily accessed i mean there's a
recent the story today about how a woman
pretended to be a rothschild and got
access
to trump's kind of inner circle so when
people say oh no no mar-a-lago and
trump's team are very secure bull
[ __ ] [ __ ] you can go [ __ ] yourself
because the guy is committing treason
and he will sell the the documents or
the secrets if he hasn't already
like that's what it is there's no other
reason to have those things
here's the conclusion of that affidavit
um
and the agents are agents and that it
appears to be one agent who wrote this
affidavit um based on the foregoing
facts and circumstances i submit that
probable cause exists to believe that
evidence contraband fruits of crime oh
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] you talking about just
getting out with it and other illegal
possessed in violation and they throw
the code on there will be found at the
premises
further i submit that this affidavit
supports probable cause for the warrant
to search the premises now the reason
why they're capitalizing premises is
because they've defined premises at
mar-a-lago uh up on the at the top of
the affidavit it's not like a it's not
like a um a trump type post where he's
like premises right you know where he's
where he's yelling they're not yelling
here they're referring to the top part
of the affidavit described in attachment
a and sees the items described in
attachment b oh c's the items described
in detachment b that's the attachment b
i'd like to see that oh there is a there
was i think
uh who did i see i saw that was already
so someone's got this going here so i'm
gonna then retweet that and give it i
think it could have been i think it was
kyle
kyle chaney had uh
oh did he have something there okay well
let's see yeah yeah exhibit b you're
talking about that one yeah um can you
can you uh send me that um we're staying
on it here now we're to do bone end of
the week um again we do it every friday
in the second hour we're we're we are
now in the second hour but uh so bone
end might be a little shorter because
we're going to stay on this news just a
bit to uh just kind of sent you the
the court listener doc okay let's um
let's um
paste
bear with us we have breaking news here
we're going to continue this is exhibit
b
so here's exhibit b holy [ __ ] yeah oh
this is this is what i was expecting
the actual affidavit to be like this
thing every [ __ ] line except two
lines are redacted
right and um um agent safety is one
which means that
they didn't
put it on there because of
because of how trump dealt well they
know they're domestic terrorists they
know they're domestic terrorists um
number four is agent safety as well i
mean in these documents they in the in
the other in the other uh affidavit or
the i guess the reasoning it might have
been the reasoning document in there
that said like here's you know uh here's
why we need to redact this information
they specifically call out what happened
with the search warrant and how trump
made a big [ __ ] deal about it and
then released it and because those names
went public those people were harassed
so anyone in the [ __ ] comments right
now that's saying like oh he
declassified documents he's totally in
his right hand he's the president one
you're totally [ __ ] wrong because
there is a process there is a procedure
in which you have to then go to those
agencies that classify them to then say
oh you know what right they got to be
marked yeah they could say now okay
those are declassified
you cannot just have a present just
waves a [ __ ] sharpie and says
declassified that's not how it works and
on top of that
when you have a president that releases
uh an unredacted search warrant or at
least part of the search warrant that
that exposes who the agents were that
were there on the scene at mar-a-lago
you lose all credibility you do not you
you do not earn any right to say
anything about this as well as the fact
you do not say oh well no everyone
should know who they are no they
shouldn't because
trump and maga and all these
[ __ ] will do whatever they can
to destroy those people that are going
against trump
i believe it now i think we have we'll
have more of this in bone head of the
week correct
yes yeah okay so let's do this let's go
to a break let's get our bearings here
we're going to go to bone end of the
week when we come back from the break um
but i think we'll continue to talk about
this bro using bonehead because surely
surely someone shows up as a
dishonorable mention here i don't know
i'm just saying look i don't know sure
they really made a case for themselves
in the last like 10 minutes when i was
making it well i'm gonna play a certain
commercial here because a lot of people
are gonna need a lot of pardons so don't
stick around when we come back we'll be
back with bone end of the week
and don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
so i guess a great question would be do
you think you believe
that there is a reality
where dark brandon would ever
would ever pardon
grandpa poopy pants for having this many
top secret documents in the full house
in melania's closet i don't think he
would ever would
no [ __ ] way so helen way is dark
brandon ever going to [ __ ] is ever
ever going to never
we should
trump said it earlier like years ago he
said how we should treat people who are
traitors how we should people people who
who go against this country well i'm
sorry to say but
you should probably be treated the way
and you will be treated the same way i
mean this is one of those things you
just wave off and go like okay well he
just can't run again right i've heard
people say that when they're like oh
well i think they'll travel well that is
one of the punishments that is one of
the punishments oh yeah most definitely
for committing one of these crimes right
you're not allowed to hold a public
holiday i mean
or be part of the federal government
right i mean like you know if you if you
can commit a felony you have now been
you know removed yourself from the the
potential running of candidates this is
one of those things like this is not
just a [ __ ] felony
this is this
national defense information which is
super important that's the other thing
about this is that more than likely
because former presidents and former
officials generally hold their security
clearances after the fact and the reason
why they hold it is because they
actually know that information
like
many people have pointed out on the
right well he he doesn't have to have
these documents he's got this
information between his brain well then
why did he need to steal him then if
that actually is the case then why does
he need to steal them so yeah so that is
why a lot of uh
public officials of our government who
have security clearances while they're
working with the government continue to
have that security clearance afterwards
but they they can lose it for sure and
this is one cause to lose it because
oh my god what a [ __ ]
he definitely is the bonehead of the
century but let's do this let's go
through your vote for bonehead of the
week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week boy gabe we have a lot of
boneheads but one worked their way in
right there at the end dude we have this
gap just the 11th hour it came in
i mean
you were making graphics and this dude
is getting eviscerated in number 47
right in this affidavit i tweeted 45
runs into number 47 on the affidavit and
that funny yeah he's number 45 they
claim he wants to be number 47 number 47
on this affidavit i don't know i mean i
also want to point out the fact that
like when when people spell out treason
with 45 it's like man that just seemed
to really work for that right
four five
o n like we got that treason right just
it works perfectly you know other than
the fact of 45 looks like the revised
swastika that i've seen people do online
but
i don't know man trump he
really put himself into a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show here
it's almost like he stole a bunch of top
secret documents stuffed them in a box
and put them in milani's underwear
drawer i'm just saying so who are our
opponents of the week this week besides
grandpa poopypants we have on the docket
we have marjorie taylor green
she's done a lot of dumb [ __ ] but this
week um she continues to do the
boneheaded stuff we have devin nunes
speaking speaking of donald trump and
his lack he's devin nunes he's bone end
of the week and then we have ben shapiro
um you know we put him on the list for
something but i think he did something
else this morning that would qualify him
to be on contestants of bonehead of the
week are you looking it up there
i don't know what he did i don't know he
didn't listen i can look it up right now
though
well yeah well thanks for joining us on
bone end of the week every single friday
for all the new listeners out there on
the tony michaels podcast here's what
happens to let you know how bonehead of
the week works you just go follow us on
twitter at tonymichaelspod or you can go
to our channel on youtube at
tonymichaelspod subscribe there and you
can vote every single week gabe for
bonehead of the week
you vote you decide and me and gabe
break it down here on the tony michael's
podcast in the second hour on friday
in the segment we like to call bonehead
of the week every single friday gabe we
got great news this week
it's always happening always updating
[ __ ] is always hitting the fan over here
as dash dabrowski says big news big news
we are on we are on the midas touch
network friday nights i'm not i don't
think we still worked out a time so
whatever time we're here
we're here that we're here so if you're
watching us on the minus touch network
on friday evenings you're watching the
replay of this show and don't miss the
replay on the midas touch network make
sure you go over and subscribe to their
channel as well you do not want to miss
this gabe the other thing for all the
new listeners for bonehead of the week
out there we put this thing up on the
directories on sundays yeah you can
listen you can even listen to the head
of the week
google drive to the park take listen to
whatever
of the week i love this segment this is
one of the best things
of the week bonehead so let's start out
let's start out let's go to devin nunez
first that won't take long to describe
why he's a bonehead so what's the trick
because
he's on here for true social right is
that what's going on so what is the
what's the big news about true social
well what do we got going on my surprise
if you couldn't have expected it which
you totally should have
uh truth social trump's social media app
that was supposed to go against twitter
truth social turns out that they might
be in significant financial disarray
it looks like they're stiffing one of
their vendors they've only made a few
payments of an agreement they've vendor
vendor what do you mean by vendor
because i think this is important um um
for true social because it sounds like
where they house all their data and all
the information that makes it operate
and run it sounds like they're not
paying the bill to be there is that
what's going on that's pretty much what
they owe around 1.6 million dollars to a
company called right forge and now right
forge is threatening legal action to
recoup the money um they've only made i
think about three payments uh i mean
like again could anyone have guessed yes
we could have from the get-go that truth
social would have stiffed anyone
that they were working with they might
make a couple payments here to show some
good faith but then they'll be like
we're not going to do anymore and that's
that's the same business practice that
trump has done with all of his
businesses right any sort of contractor
maybe pays him a little bit doesn't pay
him the rest or he just doesn't pay him
at all and then he just tries to spread
it out through court and try to fight
him that way and you know sometimes
people win and a lot of times people
lose just because they don't have the
the resource of the funds to actually
fight illegally but again
totally expected totally here is from is
from a fox business correspondent yeah
shouldn't you it was fox business who
released this scoop
the fox business network no there's fox
news is turning on trump man they had
that other people the other day that was
talking about how the search of
mar-a-lago was justified right well this
puts this is the reason why devin nunes
worked his way on bone end of the week
because he's he's also gonna he's gonna
be the fall guy for whatever happens oh
why i think i think that's the actual
story here on devin nunes is
not only are they now they're in they're
up to their eyeballs in debt now um
which is funny because i'm i'm guessing
that they'll go ask for um forgiveness
oh wait wait
you're saying that they're going to ask
for some sort of i bet they would ask
forgiveness yeah i bet they would
not not hypocritical at all or anything
like that hypocrisy thy name is the
republican party uh for fraud social to
stay afloat because that's the other
story around true social really is that
they're being investigated um by the
federal exchange commission because of
some of their when they were raising
money when they were laundering uh the
raising of money originally and then
donald trump's like hey devin nunes come
be my fall guy give up your seat in
congress and come be my fall guy that's
a good idea nunez was like
move on over i'm coming in
and there he was what what no i just you
know don't like how he hasn't said money
i mean he was very excited for sure i
mean any good cow pun obviously for a
very sensitive triggered snowflake like
devin nunes who has to sue a twitter
account
uh
really tells you who they are you know
yeah well i i just figured if if
if devin nunez is gonna say move on over
he would say
oh yeah no he would for sure
you know kind of exaggerate that out
cows don't actually say moo do you know
that they go what
oh okay yeah well i grew up on a farm so
i know i like oh right right right okay
yeah yeah so they don't they don't
actually move well i mean it sounds a
little bit like a moo but like that's
when you're trying to get a kid like
what's the cow say moo moo moo moo oh
right old macdonald right had a farm oh
mcdonald oh damn noon has had a farm
he
is oh my god who's the next bonehead
that we have
we've got uh benjamin shapiro oh what
happened here he went to a podcast event
yeah he went to a he went to a podcast
event uh there was also talks that uh
he had taken ppp loan money oh no wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
he paid it back no no no i just want to
clarify so basically he had a tweet that
went after
uh
you know it says
what was the original tweet that he had
um
it was
it was his you know the current
hierarchy education industry as
subsidized by the federal government is
a massive scam it is an elitist project
for offering unnecessary credentialism
pushing forward uh or pushing people who
shouldn't take on debt to go to college
to do so paid by progressive
retributionism now i agree i higher
education is is a broken system that
needs to be reformed in many many well
and it's like it's a cultural issue an
association not necessarily i mean
because
we put ourselves in a situation where so
many people can
you know make money
convincing people to do something with
their lives that maybe isn't the best
opportunity now so here's the here's the
problem right ben shapiro says that
higher education the the whole industry
is an elitist project fostering
unnecessary credentialism
funny funny considering the fact that
ben shapiro went to ucla which is all
about in la and this is a very very
expensive school since elitist to me
he's a little bit oldest and i mean if
we're going to talk about elite schools
let's talk where else did he go where
went to harvard he went to harvard you
taught you telling me that ben shapiro
is some kind of an elite no it couldn't
seem that way
it would seem that way it couldn't be
but but there was also this tweet it was
a a doctored photo that said ben shapiro
took out 20 000 or so dollars
uh with ppp loan money right because he
was also so this was a fake this was a
fake turns out it was fake so he did not
take out twenty thousand dollars in
forgiven ppp loan money though it it you
know that that's not to say that it's uh
it's untrue because it is true for
another contestant we have
on this week's phone head of the week
but i just wanted to clarify for anyone
listening or watching that the money
that you may have seen allegedly he had
taken in ppp money
not true not true well he showed up in
the news yesterday ben shapiro not about
the ppp but there was this thing a
podcast movement down it's like a like a
convention a podcast convention down in
dallas texas yeah we were actually we
were doing we were considering going to
it it was pretty expensive but we just
we couldn't work it out on the schedule
yeah but um the podcast movement put out
a statement because he showed up
unannounced because you had to have um
we were looking at the tickets and stuff
right yeah and you could do like a group
ticket or you could buy a booth or you
could just get like an individual yeah
just like an attendee pass right right
and you could select different uh places
that you wanted to go and different like
talks that you wanted to attend right
but they had a general conference area
where you go to booth to boot the booth
now if people won't know ben shapiro is
famously uh the vile nasty owner of the
vile nasty media group the daily wire
where people like ben shapiro show
matt walsh that [ __ ] bigot all that
all that garbage comes out of um but
podcast movement they
they actually did the thing where they
rented a booth to the daily wire and
they they regretted it very quickly
because here's their statement here's a
statement from yesterday hi folks
hi folks we owe you an apology before
sessions kick off for the day
yesterday afternoon ben shapiro briefly
visited the pm 22 which is the podcast
movement 2022 expo area which the expo
is the the you know the big conference
area near the daily wire booth though he
was not registered or expected we take
full responsibility for the harm done by
his presence
oh you can't make this [ __ ] up you can't
make this [ __ ] up so literally the uh
the podcast movement here the conference
is saying that it because ben shapiro
showed up and just his mere presence
causes harm this is a fantastic burn
here and i think they made up they made
up for the um their lack of um
wherewithal to understand that if they
rented a booth to the daily wire that
maybe just maybe uh ben shapiro would
show up they continue to say in this
thread there's no way around it
we agreed to sell the daily wire first
time booth based on the company's large
presidents and podcasting
the weight of that decision is now
painfully clear shapiro is is a
co-founder and a drop in however
unlikely should have been considered a
possibility
so they know the error of their ways but
to me to me gabe they totally made it up
by this by this statement yeah it is
totally dolly made up yeah probably made
up for it so i i would go i would
consider going to the uh the podcast
movement next year yeah just because of
this statement
i'm almost disappointed that we weren't
able to pull it together at the last
minute i think it down there adam adam
was down there right now yeah what yeah
because we interviewed um adam epstein
uh
tuesday wednesday wednesday
but here's one next year next next year
next year but here's what erdogan want
to say
i'm really disappointed that i wasn't
there to be within spinning distance of
i'm not saying i would i just within
spitting this i mean i wanted to be
close to ben shapiro you know to yell
something yeah but spitting distance of
him
to be within spinning distance of it
might might be something that i would
want to do uh who else do we have on the
bonehead we have we have someone who is
charlie kirk's stepbrother known as
alpha charlie kirk what happened here
with charlie kirk in turning points usa
oh boy well they they had a tweet which
i'm sure you can easily find now they
ended up deleting that tweet oh really
because they whoever wait wait he sells
self canceling they're they're doing
silly yeah they're they're suppressing
their own voice tony they are
suppressing their voice couldn't be
couldn't be
but
they had a tweet
that was in response to
uh the white house
and how they were calling out i believe
it was the it was the white house's
response yes it was to marjorie taylor
green it was my i quote
and this is why i always take a
screenshot tony because someone is going
to get called out and someone is going
to delete it and now
nobody knows the context of what
man look at this see i quote tweeted
their tweet because they can go to uh go
down
i've got it i've got it here i've got it
here but i'm going to this is why i take
screenshots this is what happens see i
quote tweeted him and i said you're
gonna [ __ ] when you hear who shut this
[ __ ] down yeah so there's no
context because the tweet is deleted
right i mean because i
boom boom just from yesterday but here
if you want to know
of course people of course of course
people screenshot this damn thing
because they knew they would be in
trouble midas touch says yikes that's
all you really had to say here because
here is the here's the the the
screenshot of it
the white house tweeted well it was a
whole thread really yeah and that's what
i want to get into here yeah yeah that's
why i want which yeah of course we'll
lead us into that's what i want to lead
who is our last contestant of the of the
dark house i mean the white house um
rising from the ashes here um they they
were pointing out in this thread
that um republican politicians who now
say it's unfair and people who are going
to receive the benefits of the student
debt uh relief plan that will actually
be given a one-up in their in in their
life and all the interest that they paid
it probably won't even amount the
interest that they paid over the life of
these loans for some of them
um but the white house was just simply
pointing out all the republicans who are
now saying this but were received
hundreds of thousands sometimes millions
of dollars also
forgiven
why do these people need that money
that's right well why why they need it
and why they have to have it forgiven
are they lazy is it unfair i don't know
and the other the other thing i want to
bring up is that these are people who
had
the they had uh insight beforehand they
had insider information saying they knew
that the pandemic and they needed to
know that they needed to happen well i'm
saying i mean obviously we all knew the
pandemic but they knew the extent at
which the government was going to at
least aid people and they said oh we
should offer government assistance to
businesses and those people said well i
have a business right well i've got all
i have
people i can pay you know what we should
do is we should pile on all kinds of
money for businesses just like i own
okay but turning points usa really
stepped in in here they really [ __ ]
stepped in it because this was their
response to the white house
about ppp loan forgiveness
they said we won't have ha
excuse me we wouldn't have had ppp loans
if it wasn't for you shutting down the
entire the country down you meaning the
white house right yes that's what they
meant i mean in some ways that is true
right the white house did shut down did
shut down the government they did shut
down that the government they shut down
the country right to stave off the
pandemic
actually they did shut down parts of the
government because you know they had to
do that
but who was in uh who and i that's why i
said you're gonna [ __ ] when you find out
who shut down this [ __ ] because
they apparently do not know that the
white house every four years it can
change i guess crazy crazy kind of funny
well i mean it can change if you follow
democracy right right right well yeah it
won't change if you had someone like i
don't know trump who thought that he
deserved to be the president could just
overthrow that was gonna have people
just you know storm the capital and
overthrow and change the the electors so
it gets better
um a lot of com you should go
it's too bad they deleted it but there's
plenty of people who screenshot all
their comments and stuff wait who do you
think was the president at the beginning
of the pandemic um and then
uh
and i just want to say
this took
way longer than i expected to get
deleted oh like they whoever whoever
wrote this tweet either charlie kirk or
someone within the consecutive the the
cuck conservative crew or whatever you
want to call them
they went through and they said ah man
we [ __ ] got him we so got him on this
one yeah [ __ ] they thought it was
shakalaka they probably joked about it
in a room with other people they said
yeah that's [ __ ] good man they typed
it out read it one more time to
themselves and they go yeah that's good
boom send tweet
and then you think they when do you
think they took a [ __ ] or something and
that's why i think i don't know i mean i
think they want to go do some like ball
tanning
apparently at turning points usa they
have a ball tanning room right you know
it's it's called the man room right yeah
the man room right and so they came back
and they have the boats around it yeah
they have the man
the man cave right uh but they they came
back probably at some point oh man this
this tweet's blowing up it's going viral
and they really go oh [ __ ] not for the
reason we thought oops oops olivia
points out here this is a screenshot
again from the deleted tweet she said it
brings me great joy to watch you
publicly embarrass yourselves why don't
you call your daddy donald and tell him
you didn't like his ideas because she's
so
so elegantly i mean it was a simple
duckduckgo search tony they could have
just searched a long time to figure this
out who was the president during
the shutdown right i mean right it
didn't take that long i mean really
honestly if you could be like who yeah
it's like who was the president when ppp
loans were given out
what a bonehead so that's why charlie
kirk
made it on the alpha cut because boy did
he get cucked by the internet
charlie you suck and it sucks to suck
wow that's charlie kirk for you we have
we have a dishonorable mention today and
we've been we've been talking about it
here on the show for a while and anyone
uh who missed the first part of the show
or if you're rewatching this on the
midas touch network just the bonehead of
the week part of this this the segment
uh you would know that uh this morning
as we were on the air the affidavit um
from the department of justice the
courts released the affidavit that was
used to obtain the search warrant for
mar-a-lago and so
naturally at the very last moment in the
11th hour as gabe says
donald trump became the dishonorable
mention because not only do we have our
three contestants here on bone of the
week game we put this poll out what time
was it last night that this poll went
out
oh it was late i think people people
were messaging us on twitter like yeah
you got to get them i know well i i
had my own stuff going on yesterday i
had to get my car fixed do all this
here's the crazy it was a crazy day we
used to do the bone end of the week
poland earlier in the week yeah like
monday right but what we figured out was
like it was totally irrelevant by the
time we got the friday because there's
so many [ __ ] boneheads in these manga
republicans there's so many of them that
by the time we got to friday was a
complete different setup yeah i mean
things can change as we see within just
minutes before i'm making all of the
videos and assets here like i'm like oop
this is who's going to be this this is
going to be that right that's where this
honorable mention and the alpha cut came
from right because we needed we needed
the ability to do that last minute
bonehead thing yeah and we've been doing
it we've been doing it since the first
the first episode but when we were
talking about doing this like this
little friday night or the friday show
we were like three doesn't feel like
enough we need something else right we
got it and we started we started with
this honorable mention that was the
first one right and then because of our
boy ethan schmidt oh you mean carrie
lake's uh campaign messenger exactly
yeah that is where the uh alpha cuck
out of some random
deep
abyss of my brain as we're talking about
him getting owned by a teenager we're
like you know what alpha we need a fifth
category here but we need it we need
another category there's just too many
boneheads and we gotta stop them and
really we could do like eight nine ten
twelve of these people but we just don't
have enough time i know there's not
enough time and it just becomes like
it would everyone would get an award and
look we're not part of this whole
participation award
group okay you really got to do some
bone-handed [ __ ] to win bonehead of the
weekend you've gotta really give it your
all but but this person because they
weren't on the pole but they got the
dishonorable mention i really believe
that this is like bone end of the year
type stuff oh this is affidavit this is
crazy [ __ ] man
this guy how many
how many documents let's see let me go
back to it here 67 87 oh no no 100 and a
hundred and
184 here's the 184 here's the uh
documents
individual documents this is just in the
first 15 boxes yeah so you got to
remember
nara went down and took these boxes
in may yeah right and this is this is
after this is after
they said hey we're missing this stuff
and they said we don't have this stuff
and they're like we're no we there you
have the super we're like we think yeah
we'll look around
maybe
we have it no we don't have it they're
like no you have it and they're like oh
yeah we have some we have some of it
yeah and then they went down and got 15
boxes they bring it back to dc
apparently which is also which is also
after the fact of donald trump
going through the [ __ ] files himself
picking out what he wanted and he's
touching him yeah he's like yeah this is
a good top secret yeah this might make
me some money boy this is worth a couple
million bucks kim jong-un might like
this yeah whoa i will definitely like
this one put that one in melania's
underwear drawer hey this one needs to
go in the safe we really need to make
sure no one sees it no one can crack
this safe right okay
so from may 16 to may 18th
of this year the fbi agents went through
these first 15 boxes here's what they
found gabe they found in these first 15
boxes 14 of them
had classified documents with classified
uh markings on them and that is
important when you're talking about this
they were marked classified to some
extent which is important when you when
kash patel is saying he waved his hands
over these documents and he declassified
them he did not declassify them he may
have said it out loud but they're not
declassified if they're not marked
properly he didn't do that
that's it declassification doesn't live
only in donald trump's brain that is not
how this works that's not how our
government works that's not how our
system works that's not how we protect
our national security which he is
putting in danger here but in the in out
of 15 14 boxes contained these documents
and there was 184
unique documents not pages
documents right bearing classification
markings so in these 14 boxes there was
184 files in other words of documents
i mean if you want to think of it that
way right because yeah yeah because 184
that sounds like pages but it's not
pages no no no that's actually a packet
or it could be more than one page if
that makes sense
now in that 184 game 67 of them were
marked confidential which is one level
of classification
92 were marked
secret which seems to me i mean if i
were even if i was a layman
and i didn't know anything about
classified documents or how they were
declassified or classified i would
imagine
that secret would probably be something
that i don't know you don't want anyone
to know
yeah you would think that you know if it
contains certain secrets or information
about the country that might put our
security at risk or those who might be
outside of this country like like our
people working for us yeah government to
make sure you wouldn't want to disclose
those things right
seems kind of significant well the other
significant thing here
is 25 of them 25 of these 184 documents
were marked top secret now again i'm no
classified document expert here but i
and i'm a layman and i understand that
there's confidentials one thing secret
oh that sounds even more like you don't
want anyone to know but top secret it
seems like that's a classification yeah
they're like only a few handful of
people are supposed to see if it feels
like that maybe
maybe we just keep this between us like
a little hush-hush secret like don't
tell don't tell anyone i took a cookie
out of the cookie jar kind of [ __ ] and
you're like top secret like
what
you know like i mean you know i'm not
trying to downplay just the aspect of a
secret but this is one of those things
where like confidential classified top
secret you've got skiff documents like
there is no way that you can rationalize
outside like especially any republicans
that say oh this was an unjust attack of
donald trump he should have had those
documents they agree you know now
they're beginning to say
well he shouldn't have had them
but they're still going with the
argument like uh dan crenshaw saying
this is an unjust attack on the
president totally political attack i
wonder if they're going to start
deleting those tweets i i mean you can't
delete those interviews they did last
sunday
this much this is one of those things
where it's like you guys double down and
then triple down on an argument that was
pretty dumb to begin with from like from
the start right
you decided to say oh this was either
planted this was either uh fabricated
this was political move by biden uh this
were not actually as bad as the
documents as you might you know uh
describe no it is all of those things
and worse in the fact that this was
illegally taken by a former president
that put our country at risk it wasn't
planted it wasn't fake it wasn't in a
secure location despite the fact that he
said they were in a
two locks and behind a door we're
finding out that it's in multiple
locations scattered across the [ __ ]
compound
that is not
good that is not safe the area is is not
secure and again this this affidavit is
only based on the first 15 boxes right
because in this in this 47 this item 47
here in the affidavit it goes on to say
the fbi agent says down at the bottom
based on my training and experience
which you would think that an fbi agent
would have some experience with
classified or confidential documents i
know that documents classified at these
levels typically contain ndi which is
national defense information which is
very important when you're talking about
skiffs because it doesn't matter what
the classification is a lot of times
because they're ndi they can only be
viewed in a certain area because they
have to be remain secure in a certain
way now
it goes on to say and i think this is
very important too i don't want anyone
to um
skate over this fact because i actually
think this has to do with the january 6
part of this um at the very bottom it
says several of the documents also
contain what appears to be
um
the former guy
former potus former president united
states donald trump's handwritten notes
which means that it is
the reason why the fbi brings up these
handwritten notes in this episode is
because they think him having these
handwritten notes is criminal which
means it's either crime to have him or
he's hiding a crime that he did with the
handwritten notes right there's a reason
why they they point out that it's
handwritten notes i mean it's not like
hey get me another diet coke that's not
what this is this handwritten note is
either a direction of crime or him
possessing these handwritten notes is
directly a crime because maybe he's
writing down with a sharpie notes about
classified information and briefings who
knows what these handwritten notes are
but they are handwritten notes these are
the ones he didn't eat or flush gabe
that's the one yeah what do you what do
you put what do you put on on
handwritten notes do you put ketchup on
and written notes i think it's all
ketchup is it all ketchup yeah well i
mean what else what else will help
classify
wondering just wondering when when the
average american goes to the white house
and grabs the top secret document or
goes to the mar-a-lago you know
stephen dockerman to eat what do they
put on it it's mustard it's ketchup
lettuce
it's it's a it's just a sesame seed bun
i don't know no no no the paper the
paper can be molded into a bun and i see
and the actual contents of what's inside
you know so like you fold it long way
then fold it again you've got a double
fold in the middle you throw some
ketchup on and you chase it with a diet
coke
what a [ __ ] box dishonorable mentioned
donald j trump the cheeto dust mobster
the former guy grandpa poopy pants
himself he should have been the bonehead
but we had another winner game we had
another winner yeah yeah the female
version of the former guy
marjorie
uh water green as i believe swattery
green that's right watery green
swaddlers
taylor green that's what i meant to say
but i used to call her margaery hoof
foot green but now she's been changed to
sweatery taylor green um what is it ted
marjorie taylor green stepped in that
made her because she was out front i
mean like oh we post this thing she was
the winner yeah she would be within a
matter of seconds i mean at the end of
the she i mean once people see the video
of the poll of the actual like them
going against each other it is
no not even close
even devin nunes and bin shapiro
couldn't compete with swaddling taylor
green they were like posted on twitter
at tony michael spot when we posted it
on there boom it was done oh when i
found the game on youtube boom ran out
of the gate she was the winner no
question and that's where you go vote
you can vote on youtube on our youtube
channel yeah the tony michaels podcast
you can find it on youtube or you can
you can vote on twitter at tony
michael's pod every single week and
again we we like to put it out early but
sometimes we hold on to that twitter
bowl and that that that bone in a weak
bowl for as long as we can because
the boneheads emerge the boneheads
emerge you can also download
the bod the the bone of the week every
single week
but this bone head this bone head
there's some video of her and the white
house did such a great job that's the
where i want to go with this is because
the white house destroyed uh marjorie
taylor green she was actually i think
she was in the first
part of that um she was the first one
read she was the first one
because here's the thing she and i
wouldn't be surprised if this was a
reason uh she was the most outspoken
person
that that decided to in their own
hypocrisy say that these people who had
you know worked to go to school
either
weren't able to finish or had uh
mounting loans that they don't deserve
government aid and in for giving these
loans
and how quickly
the internet was like um let's pull out
the receipts here shall we marge because
what we see here is that you took out up
to 300 or so thousand dollars and a
hundred and eighty three thousand
dollars was forgiven
so why are wait wait wait wait you mean
you mean she took out a loan that she
knew she was gonna have to pay back
right
she knew she was gonna have to pay her
income dependent on this loan of her
getting is what the assumption was and
you're saying when she had to go pay
back this loan she got a hundred and
eighty three thousand dollars of
forgiveness
it seems like that person would think
when someone goes and gets a loan for
their education i don't know for their
livelihood to think that they would get
a good job or a good paying job she
would she would actually say you know
what you should probably get some relief
if you need it but let's see what she
actually said
let's see what she actually said yeah
for for our government just to say you
know okay well your debt is completely
forgiven obviously they have an agenda
for that they need votes in november so
the timing is a pure coincidence there
as well but it's completely unfair and
taxpayers all over the country taxpayers
that never took out a student loan
taxpayers that pay their bills and and
and you know maybe even never went to
college or just hard working people they
shouldn't have to pay off the great big
student loan debt for for some college
student that piled up massive debt going
to some ivy league school that's not
fair
this is really dumb in so many levels
this video is so stupid number one she's
and she's assuming that every single
person that's getting their loan
relief for ten thousand dollars went to
an ivy league school nor does she know
that most people go to ivy league
schools are from very wealthy families
like ben shapiro for instance uh they go
to ucla and then they go to like an ivy
league like um harvard law like ben
shapiro went to and they actually their
parents pay for it out of their pocket
now there are several people that do
that work their asses off to get above
the people who can just afford to write
the check for these ivy league schools
and get in these iv schools but a lot of
times they're getting grants and they're
getting scholarships as well because
they're so goddamn smart to get into
these and also like you know i
applying for scholarships and grants are
not easy like i mean there there are a
ton you mean it's work you mean it yeah
you mean it's a lot easier
lazy people these lazy people who just
want to live off the government are
doing work to get into college come on i
mean
i can tell you well let me tell you tony
from my own experience like you know
recipient of the pell grant as well and
like taking out private loans on my
parents you know the parent plus loan
all those things like also
it's at the time when i was going to
school like there wasn't an easy way to
really i mean they were beginning to be
some ways that you could find these kind
of scholarships or grants or whatever
but
you're kind of throwing yourself out
there into the ether and being like i'm
going to apply to this and i'm also
going to be applying with thousands of
other people
for a very narrow amount of money
and i don't know if i'm going to get it
so you're out there applying applying
applying no idea if you're gonna get it
if you'll even hear back it's one of
those things where it's like
it takes a lot of [ __ ] work and the
people who are willing to do the work
right she she in her statement right now
on that show when she gave it she was
putting down she was punching down
everyone who went to and went to college
right or started to go to college and
had to drop out for whatever reason or
their their situation changed or
whatever it might be whether they
finished or didn't finish right but she
is she is pushing down
this idea that anyone who took any sort
of assistance any sort of aid
is not
uh
not not someone who should be deserving
of forgiveness
from a woman who took money
and why not like the white house so so
eloquently pointed out here and put her
on blast and the white house tweeted the
dark house i guess we should say is it
the dark white house the dark what is
this because this is the dark the dark
house the dark house rises type thing
yeah we should like the dark white house
the grey house right i don't know but
anyways congresswoman uh swattery excuse
me marjorie taylor green
had 183 thousand five hundred four
dollars in ppp loans forgiven the reason
why we know that is because it's a
government loan and it's government
information when someone gets forgiven
anyone can look these things up uh oh um
here here's the uh here's the greatest
part ah 708
a hundred thousand likes holy [ __ ] sixty
two sixty three thousand quote tweets
yeah a hundred and ninety two thousand
returns but they
they did not stop with our bone end of
the week they kept going so we have we
have another congress person vern
buchanan who had over 2.3 million holy
[ __ ] forgiven on the ppp loans the money
we the people loaned him
and we forgave that loan 2.3
million dollars [ __ ] this guy this piece
of [ __ ] because he was on um fake news
here talking about how people are lazy
let's listen here's that was sorry this
is this amount too this amount wasn't
even revealed in that uh
there was that graphic that was going
around with a bunch of people was like
matt gates martial green some other
people i don't i don't think he was
actually in our region talking about
forgiveness alone for the last four or
five months are very very upset many of
them work two jobs to be able to put
their kids through college and then to
think that a lot of these loans are
gonna be forgived is wrong and they're
very outraged about it and they've no
they're not no they're not no one's
outraged no one's outraged you dumb son
of a [ __ ] that that people who went to
school who worked hard to go through
school who either finished school or
like gabe said didn't finish school and
it participated in our economy we're
we're at record low unemployment to to
think that all the people that are going
to receive this relief are only people
who are lazy you are a dumb [ __ ]
and they are they are over calculating
here gabe they are over calculating they
are overreaching here and this is going
to backfire on him big time big time
just going to backfire him just like
vern here vern that's his [ __ ] name
vern um he got he has 2.3 million it
doesn't stop there now mark wayne
um
millen mullen
of course mullen here was talking about
how people are lazy again but he got 1.4
million million with an m
in ppp loans were given uh congressman
kevin hearn uh over 1 million he
absolutely says
that these people should not have uh
their debt relief for their hard work uh
congressman mike kelly uh pennsylvania
almost a million 987 thousand yeah shy
of a million ooh and then um a bone ed
uh uh normal
he's normally on our bone end of the
week he's i don't know how many times we
need to do that list of how many times
he's yeah we'll we'll give an updated
account to show how many times matt
gates martial green lauren bobert and
the rest of the [ __ ] fascist
seditionist group have come onto the
show well here is matt gatz saying he
tweeted everyone knows
that in a 60 billion plus european land
war it's always
the last three billion that kicks in the
door and i don't know what he's tweeting
here the truth
it was oh oh here the three billion
dollars in for an aid to ukraine he's
talking about ukraine he's a putin's i
gotta say i'm surprised that all of
these tweets have not been deleted by
these people well you know it they
probably they got so many vile tweets it
would be difficult to start deleting
them
482 thousand dollars matt gatz got
forgiven by the federal government by us
but the main person here
um swattery taylor green
this week now revealed which again it's
public information she's punching down
on the american working class receiving
just a slight benefit to help them
relieve their debt which probably in
most cases and even the amount of
interest that people have paid on these
loans throughout the years
she received 183 000
in ppp forgiveness that's why she is the
bone end of the week gabe let's give
this bonehead her due
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so watery taylor green hookfoot green is
born into the week
you voted you decided we broke it down
just as we do every single friday in the
second hour of the tony michaels podcast
don't forget to subscribe on youtube at
the tony michaels podcast we air live
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter and twitch
and we simulcast from the midas touch
facebook page and every friday we bring
you bonehead of the week
right here on the tony michaels podcast
and re-airing on midas touch network
don't forget to subscribe to the minus
touch network as well keep up with all
your breaking news why it's important
and how to spread that message and you
can vote on the youtube channel or
follow us on twitter at tonymichaelspod
where you can vote for bonehead of the
week you can also download bonehead of
the week every single week on sunday
apple spotify google your favorite
directory while you're there please
leave us a review and please subscribe
to the audio podcast
this has been this edition of bonehead
of the week
head of the week we'll see you next week
stick around we have some great
announcements on the tony michaels
podcast right after the music
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week
boom
that's done that's done
thank you for joining us week we
appreciate you guys sticking around with
the audience is growing and growing and
growing don't forget to visit
store.dtonymichaels.com for all your
doubt me merch stickers coffee cups
hoodies shirts everyone's been this
stuff's been going like hotcakes over
there bam hotcakes hotcakes also support
pro-democracy speech everywhere but if
you want to support this show you can go
to
support.tonymichaelspod.com the link is
right right right there right there
right there kind of right there yeah
right there it's right there
support.tonymichaelspod.com or you can
go to the qr code there you can use that
if you're fancy enough you can also go
to thetonymichaels.com
the links are all in my bios um and you
can find the link for the support and if
you want to support our free democracy
speech we appreciate that we appreciate
having all you here every single week
day monday through friday noon eastern
11 central nine pacific on two hours a
day two hours a day two hours a day
thanks for sticking around for bone end
of the week our favorite segment here on
the tony's michael's podcast have a
great weekend great weekend
don't forget same time same place
monday noon eastern
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking